depuis le début de l'épidémie de
coronavirus la communauté asiatique de
france est la cible d'actes et de propos
racistes
le racisme anti asiatique n'est pas
nouveau déjà en 2003 lors de l'épidémie
de strass venant de chine des réactions
similaires étaient constatés à paris
terrorisée par la pneumopathie atypique
les parisiens ont littéralement déserté
le xiiie arrondissement - 50 % de
fréquentation
une catastrophe pour ce restaurateur
quand j'étais revenu mais en remontant
encore plus loin dans les archives de la
télévision française
on se rend compte que les médias eux
mêmes ont forgé un inconscient
populaires ou les asiatiques seraient
riches discret et vulnérable exemple en
1979 lorsque le journaliste de france 3
décrit la communauté chinoise de la
ville de rennes commentaires sans
trucage ils sont partout discret petit
effacés parfois on dirait assimilés on
ne connaissait rien des chinois il ya
quelques siècles et aujourd'hui c'est
encore un peu la même chose une autre
planète a dit alain peyrefitte dans son
best-seller la chine les chinois
évoquent toujours en nous le mystère la
complexité
la chine s'est toujours les baguettes la
porcelaine les estampes les dragons les
tapis les boudins
les années passent le ton est prêt
tempéré mais les clichés restent à
chaque reportage les mêmes poncifs dit
que les chauffeurs de taxi asiatique ce
relais est que pendant qu'alain qui
travaillent en un qui dort dans le
coffre est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
dort dans votre corps
jamais cette commune était plutôt
discrète en france on compte seulement
un demi millions d'asiatiques mais leur
poids économique est impressionnant
malgré un certain mystère qui entoure
leur activité l'épidémie de coronavirus
a fait resurgir ce racisme latent pour
se défendre et le dénoncer le hashtag je
ne suis pas un virus est repris sur les
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]